hey hey we can meet you I've been dying
to try this place I actually met the
chef once at a gallery opening a
Bushwick of my ex-girlfriends for solo
chefs like a video performance service
sorry
traffic on the 101 this is Veronica
I met her by the pool is it cool if she
joins us uh so you're from Chicago
yeah but like the actual city not the
suburbs actually sitting in on another
meeting right now
big-time investor series a stuff I'm
gonna have to call you back all right
so what startup do you work at mommy
what do you stay we go dancing like
salsa no no no mommy no no I got this
place I can get you in with a friend for
free huh Mira
boom boom nollie hi there
I left my case in the pedicab you look
really nice
man it is pouring out there you told me
you're second to Renee like almost left
oh I don't have a cell phone you have
any test tube shots what are you doing I
was gonna catch up on my hot dog yeah
I'm working part-time at the Coffee Bean
& Tea Leaf but probably not for much
longer my web series is about to take
off that sounds like my friends man
would I know it oh no no no they're
really underground you have to see my
niece he's super cute bro oh that's my
car BMW i8 serious racing there really
isn't it like 70 out no it's like 65 now
my parents Sara low conservative don't
let that scare you I am nothing like
them I just wish I wasn't compared to
they work all the time to be honest
you're much nicer wait you dated LA yeah
what no no he's just he's so fake oh
yeah love New York he's great
do you have any hobbies or anything have
to go the bathroom
so what do you like to use are useful
thinking beautiful maybe you want to
come back to my place I have is great to
be on Williamsburg but I share with only
seven other guys want to get out of here
and go to taco deli
wait are you not a casting director what
no yeah this isn't gonna work
holy [ __ ] how did this happen yo
waitress